normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Snow
White and the Seven politically correct
Companions and uh uh I think it's fair
to say so so let's let's go through the
timeline here's a photo uh exclusive
pictures of of Snow White's Seven
Companions uh one is a little person
because I guess dwarf is offensive even
though dwarf was the mythical dwarfs who
are made from Stone crafted from the mud
of mountains or whatever they decided
that was an insult towards little people
but uh this I think is is specifically
because when they announced they're
making the movie Peter Dinklage
complained yeah that's right they
probably behind the scenes were like
okay if we do this are we going to get
yelled at okay let's not do this so they
released this photo yeah the most famous
dwarf actor says that it's insulting to
hire dwarf actors he's the only one who
wants to have a job he doesn't want
anyone else on it so I want to make sure
everybody sees this timeline from the
daily wire on October 16th Daily wire
announces live action Snow White and the
evil queen starring YouTube sensation
Brett Cooper the bombshell announcement
comes alongside the release of the
company's kids streaming at bentkey and
then we have this October 28th from
insidethemagic.net Disney whitewashes
Snow White after diverse casting
backlash CGI caught by fans so only
about a couple weeks later they released
this photo of Rachel zagler wearing the
traditional dress surrounded by GI white
dwarves so white was I think that was
you guys I think you you said this
earlier yeah I I think that we certainly
played an outsize role obviously there
was a lot of backlash Beyond just us but
we took very direct action we put our
money on the line to directly challenge
them and you know two weeks is the speed
of light for a corporation the size of
of Disney you can just look at this CGI
photo that they released It's So Below
the quality standards of of Disney who
are the greatest animators you know in
all of human history they obviously
rushed this thing out this is Crisis
management and I think that we uh if we
weren't the entire crisis I think that
we were the most acute part of the
crisis for them at that time I I think
it's the announcement of your Snow White
that made them say oh no they so uh the
previous segment we're talking about how
Disney is admitting to their
shareholders this is from the end of
their September end of their was it uh
quarter quarter three MH and uh in
September so this is a month before you
guys announced they are outright telling
their their shareholders we are losing
money because of a misalignment
misalignment between the the content and
the culture we make and what the public
actually wants that's in sep the end of
September they know this yeah in October
you announce and I guarantee there's
someone at Disney being like what
happens when Disney Snow White bombs and
daily wire Snow White breaks records
that is going to be the Disney brand
falling into the toilet they're going to
try taking their writers because Disney
has no substance or stories with any
meaning at all and that's why people
aren't connecting with it they're going
to screw this up too oh yeah obviously
well what they'll do with this I I think
and I think that the the photo sort of
speaks to this is it will just be a beat
for beat retelling of the 37 film right
can can they screw that up sure
but good thing they have going for them
it will be hard to screw up because they
have one of the great animated films of
all time to model it after that's true
but I think they're going to screw it up
yeah yeah I think they'll slip things in
there so if you take a look at the
Marvels why it so uh if you the Marvel
movies plan after Robert dowy Jr was
Brie Larson would take over as as the
the central figure with Captain Marvel
replacing Iron Man as the centerpiece
but she was so despised in the press for
being this woke angry leftist and and
and to be fair it's not just wokeness
she really did not mesh well with the
other actors zegler is doing the same
thing she is coming out snoody snide
condescending arrogant and overly woke
I think that's going to cause them
problems for this film I think they're
going to you're right they're going to
do a shot for shot remake but they're
going to have PR problems cuz of her
well I think they've had another problem
you look at this photo of her with the
CGI dwarves and the question that I have
is is she even in this photo did they do
a photo shoot they she is a living
breathing human and sure there's a lot
at stake at pissing off well at pissing
off Disney but how are they going to get
her to keep her mouth shut about this
they haven't been able to get her to
shut her mouth up until now they they've
replaced the faces of actors before on
movies haven't they when when someone
like messes up and like we got to just
replace that person maybe they'll do
that to her cuz look they kind of like
surrounded her with the patriarchy in
this picture they just took a bunch of
white dwars like you know what this is
what you get think there's Sneezy
patriarch and grumpy patriarch but think
about it maybe it's possible this
actress never actually believed any of
the garbage and was just saying this
because her agent and Disney were like
this this is what we're going for and so
she said okay I'll say these things on
the carpet I think the likelihood is
she's woke well I'll go a little further
and just say I don't know how she 20
years old 22 years old or something
she's just a kid I I I've said a lot of
bad things about her lately because she
put herself in a position where I need
to publicly oppose her but at the end of
the day on a human level I have a lot of
sympathy for dumb kids being dumb kids
for sure you know but I I I just got to
say I I got to push back we we got to
stop calling 22-year-olds children no
you know I actually appreciate you call
me out on this I I went on at length
about this uh public not two weeks ago
that we infantilize adults by calling
them kids right she is young and she's
particularly young in the way that our
culture measures age today and so I have
some sympathy for her but you're right
she is no kid she's an adult she has
agency she's responsible for her actions
and I I take that rebuke yeah and I
think because I I was talking about this
earlier too we need to REM like the the
Millennials are our Lost Generation I'm
sorry guys I know everyone's like but
Tim your Millennial I know but uh I
talked about the survey last week
Boomers Gen X and gen Z all say they
will be comfortable with 120,000 a year
Millennials the one generation they say
they need half a million half a million
a year yes yes and there's some weird
thing that happens and I know she's what
22 so she's actually gen Z I believe
then right it's not it's not absolute
it's not one for one but we need to
start telling people like you need to be
an adult you need to start taking care
of yourself but that being said imagine
she is genuinely woke genuinely opposes
patriarch and all that and then one day
like you said is she even in this photo
they they rushed out CGI they they
cranked this photo out I imag I imagine
she gets blindsided by this oh the
oldest whitest Bob
Iger right M just takes away her little
dream that's right yes and and she's
contractually obligated I wonder if she
got an angry phone call what is this I
don't want to be a part of this it's
insulting and ableist wasn't it not just
her saying this wasn't it uh isn't
Wonder
Woman wasn't she also saying she was but
if you watch the clips with galado and I
realize I'm being very soft here on on
all of these guys which isn't my usual
reputation but if you watch gadoo
standing beside her saying things like
we're not going to be saved by The
Prince and you can kind of tell that
galado is trying to be generous to this
young woman standing next to her she's
also trying to like be one of the girls
and be on the team you know she's trying
to to have friends y you know I just I I
I cannot stand
how feminists insult women and I'll tell
you why it's not just feminist I
understand that back in the day men
would laugh at oh my wife goes shopping
oh gez and I'm just like there's this
article that was put out today that
claims women are better Hunters than men
and that this univers yeah right
Jeremy's face is like are you kidding me
yeah they said women actually can do
endurance better than males can which
means pre in prehistoric days they were
hunting more than we realize and we're
better and I'm like no just stop shut up
women going and Gathering and protecting
and raising children is Honorable and
extremely important but in this
malthusian political era where they
despise the creation of More Humans they
have to insult women for being
caregivers the greatest technological
advancement since fire is not the
printing press it's not the Internet
it's not electricity it's the sanitary
napkin and the thing that no one really
can contemplate in today's day even
women today are
a woman today is so disconnected from
Every Woman Who Lived before the 20th
century that she can't really even
imagine what life was like I know that
women weren't the great hunters in days
of your because they were pregnant all
the time right or had tiny babies that
they were nursing all the time or
couldn't leave the cave for one out of
every handful of weeks because well and
that's still happens in Nepal I was
going to say you can look at India and
Nepal today uh and and it's still
happening you have to look for it but
it's still happening and the life of a
woman in
Pre industrial times for this particular
reason is so different than we can
possibly imagine it just it's just we we
live on the other side of of sanitary
napkins and birth control pills and we
and we think that we know what women
have been like throughout all of history
that's absurd so they they they make
this narrative Snow White is insulting
when in fact it is beautiful of course
it's beautiful yeah and and
all of these other tropes about women
and their desires and what they want I
was uh reading that why do women like
shopping because it's the modern
equivalent of gathering and I'm like I
think it's because they like pretty
things well that's why I go shopping but
why why do you like pretty things
colorful things in the wild berries and
fruits the reason why uh women can see
more more shades of different colors the
reason why women are more likely to be
tetrachromats seeing with uh uh The
Wider spectrum is because uh the idea
being and I'm not saying it's 100%
correct but it's plausible women are
gathering collecting foraging extremely
important for human civilization and men
were hunting MH so men have spatial
reasoning and like they can map things
better but women create human beings
yeah they do these studies all the time
you like put men and women in a circle
in a room and over time all of the women
begin to lean in and all of the men
begin to lean out looking for Predators
it's just oh wow we're just wired
Camille paga talks about that with the
uh women in Italy and she talks about
how um absurd it is now that women and
men are meant to do the exact same type
of job and she talks about in the old
villages the women would gather around
you know the well or the pump and this
is this comes up in new hampson as well
and the growth of the soil and all of
that stuff um you know women create
these communities and it really is kind
of tragic that these communities have
fallen apart because that's where you
would learn um things about raising your
children that's where you would learn
things about preparing food and making
clothing and all of these kinds of
things and now it's just gone yeah
building Community is something that
women are uniquely good at and you know
so I'll self promote for a minute we
we've just released the trailer
yesterday for this new film that we're
doing called lady Ballers and I give a
speech in the film about the difference
between men and women and I you the
whole film you're seeing men just
completely dominate women sports thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net